bonsoir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
première réaction à ces annonces des
manuels macron notamment le pass
sanitaire qui va rendre la vie vraiment
extrêmement compliqué à tous les non
vaccinés en france des mois je voudrais
que les choses soient claires parce que
nous avons besoin du courage de la carte
et je ne suis absolument pas contre les
vaccins
je ne suis ni pour ni contre le vaccin
contre le virus
mais je pense que chacun devrait avoir
le droit d'option et je considère que
d'obliger la population à se faire
vacciner ce qui devient inévitable
compte tenu du passeport sanitaire qui
est mis en place constitue une atteinte
à la liberté de disposer de son propre
corps et je trouve que ce n'est pas
normal
encore une fois chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut je ne dis pas qu'il
ne faut pas se faire vacciner moi je ne
dis pas non plus que il faut se faire
vacciner sous peine d'être considéré
comme le dit monsieur kouchner comme un
traître ou rendez compte on en est bon
je dis que chacun devrait dans le
respect des gestes barrières dans la
prudence faire comme il l'entend et je
trouve que la manière dont s'instaure 7
cette dictature vaccinale 1 puisque si
on n'est pas vacciné on pourra plus
sortir de chez soi donc ça veut dire que
il faut se faire vacciner par contrainte
et tous les gens qui comme moi sont
obligés de se déplacer comment
pourrait-il ne pas se faire vacciner
alors même que alors même que c'est un
point important si vous le permettez
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
ce vaccin est conditionnel et qu' on en
est encore en essais cliniques de la
phase iii ou iv alors là la contrepartie
qu on devrait exiger pour cette
vaccination obligatoire c'est que
l'union européenne rende publics les
contrats qui lient l'union au
laboratoire que chaque citoyen sache
dans quelle condition le produit qu'on
va de contrainte de lui injecter a été
achetée négocier existe-t-il des clauses
d'irresponsabilité y at il des clauses
de sauvegarde enfin voilà là il y aurait
une contrepartie quand même qui serait à
mon avis indispensable et qu on doit
exiger que les que les démocrates
doivent exiger maintenant encore une
fois je voudrais absolument pas que
cette querelle sur la vaccination
devienne un fruit de discorde entre
français parce que là maintenant les
gens commencent à s'opposer d'une
manière qui rationnelle il ya ceux qui
sont pour le vaccin ceux qui sont contre
le bac ça et ça va finir par une
empoignade ça et finalement quand on
écoute quand on écoute nous apprend on
devrait conclure là dessus si vous
permettez lui rappeler ce que disait
monsieur dupont moretti vous savez le
ministre de la justice
quand il était question de vacciner
obligatoirement les prisonniers ils
disaient les détenus ne sont pas des
cobayes
on ne les vaccine rappaz de force
ah bon les détenus ne sont pas des
cobayes mais ceux qui ne sont pas
détenues sont maintenant en détention
sanitaires bon il ferait bien de
réfléchir
le président de la république à ce que
disait son ministre de la justice
aujourd'hui clairement vous êtes avocat
avant tout gilbert collard est ce que ça
pose comme nous le disaient nos invités
précédent avec senseo notamment docteur
en droit public les des problèmes tout
simplement sur le plan de la légalité
une forme de vaccination obligatoire
sans la nommer sachant qu'elle est
vraiment en revanche pour les soignants
on va vous dire c'est l'éternel argument
mais il ya des vaccins qui ont été
rendus obligatoires
c'est vrai mais ce sont des vaccins qui
avait une antériorité que l'on avait mis
des années et des années et des années à
mettre au point et qui avait quand même
été testé et il y avait la sécurité du
temps écoulé alors est ce qu'on pourra
recourir devant des juridictions comme
le tribunal administratif le conseil
d'état le conseil constitutionnel bien
sûr espérons qu'ils se lèveront en
gardiens de nos libertés
d'autant que rappelez vous ces vaccins
n'agissent pas sur les variants alors
ils diminuent c'est vrai semble t-il
en ce qui concerne la vie lui le virus
premier il diminue l'effet de la maladie
semble t-il il n'est fini par donner moi
indiqué que c'est tous les vaccins sur
le marché français était aujourd'hui
efficace contre les variants c'est ce
qu'il a dit en début dé locution oui le
feuillet plein d'études qui disent le
contraire alors là bon mangez pas me je
n'ai pas la compétence qui me
permettrait de discuter de la question
médicale mais je suis un simple lecteur
et je lis des habits très très contraire
très différents bon il ya plein de
spécialistes qui disent que c'est pas
efficace sur les variants qui il ya même
le professeur pire aux morts qui a
indiqué que ça pouvait avoir un effet
sur les variants le vaccin ben d'ogone
et dans une incertitude quoi dans un
personne ne peut avoir la prétention de
détenir la vérité
mais au moins le doute devrait
bénéficier aux vaccinés qui ne veut pas
l'être en tout cas si emmanuel macron
avec une arrière-pensée d'ailleurs elle
ne s'en cache pas objectif vaccination
17000 rendez vous après toutes les
minutes sur le site d'octo lives
incident qui a fini par être tout
simplement planté à l'heure qu'il est
possible de prendre aucun rendez vous
c'était finalement une bonne stratégie
si on voulait pousser à la vaccination
aujourd'hui oui mais sais tu sais si
c'est la stratégie du père fouettard qui
ne va pas forcément contenter les fautes
et les gens se sont dit comme beaucoup
d'amis à moi bas et que si on va aller
au café si on veut aller au restaurant
si on veut prendre le train vous rendez
compte si si le 1 1 car il faut qu'on
soit vacciné 6 ou alors il faut qu'on
aille faire un test avec toutes les
complications de d'emploi du temps que
cela représente donc les les gens sont
allés pour ne pas être trop emmerder se
faire vacciner je les comprends et je
les comprends je ne les je ne les juge
pas je ne les condamne pas je les
comprends mais je trouve que le temps
dira où est la vérité du reste le temps
le dira la hyène
il ya une verdict auquel personne
n'échappera dans cette triste affaire de
la pandémie
c'est le temps le temps sera un juge
effroyable pour ceux qui ont pris des
décisions bonnes ou mauvaises
alors une fois que la pandémie sera
maîtrisée apparemment plusieurs réformes
vont être appliquées c'était l'une des
grandes annonces de la soirée également
l'assurance maladie ça ce sera
l'assurance pardon chômage assez décrié
ce sera à partir du 1er octobre suivi
donc de la réforme des retraites par la
nécessité de pousser l'âge légal de la
retraite la fin des régimes spéciaux une
réaction la réforme des retraites si
j'ai bien compris
tant que la pandémie sera là la réforme
ne sera pas tout à fait voilà mais le
mais si on a l'impression
vous pas être désobligeant mais que le
président de la république était un peu
un voyageur de commerce des mots avec
tous ces mots valises dans lesquelles il
n'ya il n'y a rien il n'y a rien car
comment va-t-il financer quand il nous
dit cela ne coûtera rien mais il se
moque du monde il se moque du monde et
il est à dix mois de l'élection il
découvre maintenant que l'insécurité
sévit que la situation économique est
dramatique au passage quand il a parlé
de l'insécurité
ne croyez vous pas qu'il aurait pu avoir
un mot pour ce jeune théo 18 ans
assassinée par un ressortissant étranger
qui était non pas en situation régulière
mais dans le titre de séjour expiré dans
quelques mois et qui avait été
longuement condamné déjà y aurait pu
avoir un mot non bah il a même pas eu
voiliers et ça je lui reproche
merci en tout cas gilbert collard
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre réaction après l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron